what is happening reject nation I'm Greg
elder I am John Humphrey yes you are so
today we thought you know what
Hollywood has so many cinematic
universes you know we got the MCU MCU
the [ __ ] usually see a new guitar see
our new universe the conjuring delivery
universe and people are talking about
making a fast and furious after a few
never James Bond neighbors on you
there's a monster universe Kong and
Godzilla and various kind of being oh
sure there's ten more we're probably
missing right now yeah
there's a whole universe out there so we
thought let's get in on the fun let's do
that welcome to a segment that we will
probably do every once in a while ha ha
our song where we have enough excess
energy and when we just come up with
something spontaneously today is pitch
your cinematic universe we don't have a
little gopher this'll get graphic
someday someone's a bit of graphic for
us we'll use it I have a few written
down and I thought like okay some of
these are going to be might be plausible
that could actually work and some of
that would just flat-out stupid and
silly this is going to be an experiment
so let's just start out with one that
could kind of work actually one that I
could see possibly working because you
know what cinematic universes are
ridiculous and I'm already sick of them
and I hate hearing announcement of them
yes but why not throw something out to
Hollywood while we're at it yeah so
here's what the first one is that will
introduce you guys the Nintendo
Cinematic Universe yes the ncnc you I
thought always thought of another one
what I don't want you to go shoot him
soon Nintendo Cinematic Universe I've
always thought that out of all the video
games and now we have so many failed
adaptations of video games that
ecologies universe is coming on board
I've constantly joked and then then from
joking thought you know what this could
kind of work actually the Nintendo
Cinematic Universe is one that could
work because in the video game world of
Nintendo games of the most popular
characters they have crossover games and
we're talking like Super Mario Zelda
Donkey Kong starfox Metroid Samus
Megaman you know the next Super Smash
Brothers Mario Party Super Smash would
be like your avenger that's what that's
my point they'd like that pointing hands
yeah yeah go to go up against a giant
and another thing we don't have is an
animated Cinematic Universe so I thought
how cool would this be if we did these
video game adaptations of these computer
animated games but did it with like
hand-drawn animation like you know the
good old Disney style whereas it's like
all the details you know I feel like
Brad Bird could do a really good one of
these yeah yeah Han because you know
what he did Incredibles and ratatouille
keep it has Iran and then he did
computer over it something that a lot of
computer animation we just don't do
because of the attention to detail and I
think you could really do that here and
the other cool thing is to kind of like
how the MCU is been doing it like
crossing genres with their superhero
films you get a different genre out of
each one of these before they come
together and that's what would make it
still interesting like let's say we
launched with Nintendo's spearhead
Nintendo's Batman or actually defend of
Superman you know but yeah yeah he's
always trying to do the right thing yeah
and then riding colorful yeah is
Superman super not man Mario yeah Super
Mario you had a neighbor Laurie you had
a good idea for like the kind of genre
it could be these have to be like
uniquely Nintendo II but they also need
to be movies cuz it stands about Mario
you don't know a ton about the guy no
and so over the course of Mario move
you're going to have to do that so if
you did a super Mario movie they kind of
had a tone like the lego movie but maybe
I'm just a little a little more fun in
Sam life like I feel like yeah you can
do like how the Lego movies have been
going like Lego Batman lego ninjago
movie yeah yeah where it's meta
self-aware it's a comedy but it's also
very fantasy filled so you can make fun
of it yeah because they would have pace
and heart and it would to have all that
stuff that you loved and it would
probably do that thing where they bring
you into the element of what it was you
about playing it to begin yeah exactly I
feel like this would be a good Phil Lord
and Chris Miller type of movie to make a
Super Mario movie I mean you know with a
distinct Nintendo tone I'm a total it
ever that is or any yeah you got all the
classic characters in the mario world
enough as it is you know yeah no Mario
Luigi Yoshi toh dowser and Bowser is one
of the main villains and I for one just
I want to make the Luigi's Mansion movie
oh yeah yeah you could have spin off
swim again you burn many universes in
the universe you can Rho about Yoshi
event on Netflix
working out version out and then you
could do gsella which of course would be
like your Lord of the Rings I have a
fantasy movie yeah or your Aragorn era
gosh Princess Mononoke Princess Mononoke
yeah
but how cool would that be you get your
Zelda film when I was up against
Ganondorf has to save link as to save
Zelda so that would be like your fantasy
dome so your first one has kind of the
comedy meta you know
Lego movies file second one has that
Lord of the Rings animated Game of
Thrones like an edgy pg-13 animated
still yeah and then you know because you
can mix it up or if you if you want to
smoothly transition this is a little ah
pick up by the whip net and if you want
a smoothly transition I would actually
go Super Mario then Donkey Kong because
Donkey Kong you know that has what we
said was like after looking at gameplay
footage again because been so many years
of laplacian we could be its kind of has
its like Jumanji meets Pirates of the
Caribbean vibe that's how it translated
a movie yeah exactly go on this
adventure through you know the jungles
and stuff like that and he goes on
pirate ships the main villains a pirate
king or something like this our my feet
I beat the Super Nintendo game so many
times I don't remember it that one does
have like the pirate elements that's the
adventure elements and you know it's
like it's crazy ridiculous and I think
this will work as animated
worst-case motion capture dude hey get
johnny Knoxville to play donkey and ammo
caddy searches the donkey [ __ ] jockey
cog yeah yeah you can make like a go
like a really fun swashbuckling you know
this sort of ate the ruby baby
yeah it needs a third APUs all I baking
okay it's so like King Kong he's written
a donkey [ __ ]
you got Diddy Kong and Dixie Johnny come
Amalie got the Kong family and I think
isn't Diddy Donkey Kong 2 is Diddy
Kong's adventures and then part 3 is
Dixie Kong right I think so yes I don't
remember how they all fit together
because there's like Donkey continent
like I can never keep track of which
ones have subtitles and which ones are
just like Donkey Kong yeah you know like
yeah yeah and then I feel like what
would be a good like third one to
transition into I'm feeling a Star Fox
because that getting into the fantasy
sci-fi but Star Fox will still be fun
because that would be like the Star Wars
guardians of the galaxy style type of
movie I would go I would go Super Mario
because that's your that's your flagship
that's the heart and soul of your vibe
then you would do Donkey Kong and then
you would make that sort of you know fun
and swashbuckling one the epic one yeah
like big epic third I would do Zelda
like I would read that I would put Zelda
in at that because like three is kind of
a crucial number I would do Star Fox
number four but I would do Zelda first I
thought everyone could because that one
will be a little more serious and darker
and then starfox would have a have a
blend of like cool action movie with
bringing the humor back in more because
they'll die imagine to be a much more
serious type of film yeah yeah and it's
you know it's that more fantasy as you
know it's your own illusion board to
bring this ya only represent Game of
Thrones like a pg-13 type of version I
don't like to be like a peanut of the
spirit of the game yeah I have a one
that also may be an animated pg-13 film
and then after zelda that's when you can
get into starfox ah that was my jam that
reviewed I think starfox bet out of all
the Nintendo ones I feel like Starbucks
should be bit one mission if you're not
going to make any of them do Starbucks
yeah how I feel that wouldn't be so good
movie do a barrel roll do a barrel roll
man it would be so much fun
Star Fox was the best that is space
adventure space opera dude if you Moke
oh my god if you mo cab demo cabochon
burns all its out good Sam Elliott can
you pet me or so this is technically
he's hot right now
you could get Michael Keaton to play and
you're off
Oh out placeas and you could you after
the post-credits you could do some kind
of nod to like at the end it's just his
eyes and brain yeah you beat it across
the left map yeah you know kind of how
like marbles going into like cosmic
territory so now we've got a cosmic
character in Star Fox then we could go
into like Metroid oh yeah it's like you
do your fun fantasy rogue one style with
Starbucks and then you would bust into
that you know Metroid which we have a
neo blog years of comic book movie yeah
like movie like the Nintendo version of
Neill Blomkamp alien yeah that's what
that feels like
so that's right and then you can do
megaman after that which is like the
ghost in the shell is Robo Weaver -
voice salmon's Oh
dude our work because I know there's
other Nintendo games and I'm like this
would be the Saudis would be the
Avengers team right here this would be R
star players meet our justice league
team I mean how cool would it be because
then when you do your crossover movie
you know Mario and Donkey Kong going
toe-to-toe because remember that in the
Donkey Kong Hong Kong the villain in the
arcade game yeah he kidnapped oil
barrels journal is better than so you
could have them having their
competitiveness with each other
I could see Metroid Samus and Megaman
not getting along at first link and one
of those before maybe doing a team-up
adventure like yeah yeah I could kind of
sees link bursting the starfox team for
some reason I don't know why I can see
it's oh my god see you know like a
portal versus nurture something like his
launch to the future yeah and we learned
that these and imperfect animals they're
down the tub it is some type of crazy
crossover movie could be your Super
Smash Brothers movie or it gets to your
Mario Party movie they'll just get
together party because Nintendo has an
inherent
usually has an inherent fundis about it
even when there are you know like
strange or jarring fantasy elements and
so like yeah you can you can have a lot
of flexibility in here to jump around
and bend the rules and eventually you
know you can vary up all the styles even
visually this is more of just a
free-form of you know it could be cool
and that's what we're doing here yeah
plus now we're we're one step closer to
that big-budget protoman movie again
before all these years well yeah guys is
there a Nintendo Cinematic Universe what
do you what do you think could you get
on board with
one mores universe because this is the
one I think they should do did they
announce one this morning or something
like make the joke obsolete tell us is
it Calais Nintendo if you like our idea
take it you don't need to pay us we
would like like a special thank you at
the end like the credits for no one
stays for yeah just put our house credit
scene would be a the teach for the next
Nintendo yeah just be a kid rifling
through a jeweler and then picking out a
new cartridge is good I think would be
cool that is they're all different
animated styles to you yeah because
that's the thing they all have very
distinct looks and then nobody called
across them over yeah plus then when you
get like four or five phases deep you
know you can start breaking out and then
you can finally have your IGN Zelda
live-action movie oh yeah line you know
and then you could do some kind of that
you could do like a live-action dong
dong with mocap I got I got okay look
link he hops into Mario's world and then
he says they still haven't made and then
he goes to one of those you know yeah
comes out of the real world and
everything looks different it's real
that would be off it surprises still
existed that would be amazing
yeah all right guys oh yeah there's our
Nintendo Cinematic Universe see this is
how genius is develop cinematic
universes we have proven to you this is
the writers room you guys are in right
now aren't you excited for what
Hollywood has in store subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
though yeah John Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram social media manager of blonde
house calm and please go check out our
patreon for exclusive person exclusive
rewards would love for you to be a part
of the community over there this we got
plenty of people over there right now
would love for you to be one of the
joini and hey we got t-shirts go check
them out